re re too oh
min
today is the end of the month I've been waiting for Suma Ichigo's previous
job guarantee has been paid in Hanyu's stable topic It's the
end of the month
eh
par
ame
I'm glad I didn't have to worry about Saidou I just
paid  Because I'm here, Yunko I'm
a stone of use for money I
can't help you next time You can
contact me this time
Actually, I haven't paid my cell phone bill
.
But it's fine,
but if I can't afford to eat it, it means nothing.
What the hell, except for the yamakasa I've been looking for
[Applause]
I'll wipe the filming site
.
You know, Shu-kun, you can really
do it, and if you hit someone and blow the putter, you'll get
a sword before and after
[music]